A Navy seal described as a serial killer by
some was pardoned by Donald Trump and he is
capitalizing on his newfound fame, which came
from being pardoned for horrible crimes by
becoming a right wing influencer, Hawking
all sorts of different products.
This is the story of Eddie Gallagher.
Eddie Gallagher was a Navy seal chief petty
officer.
He posed with the body of a dead Iraqi child
while in Iraq he allegedly committed multiple
war crimes including killing a 15 year old.
Ultimately, he was acquitted of everything
other than posting a picture with the dead
kid and Donald Trump granted him clemency
in November and this became a big thing and
this has turned Eddie Gallagher into an influencer
for salty frog gear.
He now sells t-shirts and supplements much
in the style of conspiracy theorist Alex Jones.
He's selling coffee beans.
He's selling muscle builders, things that
have a kill bad dudes logo on them.
This guy is being celebrated by the American
right?
For what?
They have a shirt that says waterboarding
instructor making money, bragging about torture.
That is part of the disgusting and dark history
of what the United States has done.
His fellow Navy seals have said, this guy
is quote toxic quote, freaking evil and a
murderer who quote wants to kill anybody he
can.
Trump has called Gallagher quote, one of the
ultimate fighters.
I think the New York times probably deserves
some credit here as well.
They did a profile of this sky and all of
the products that he's promoting without even
really talking about the guy's past.
If you want to critique the horrors of Donald
Trump, granting him clemency and the guy becoming
a right wing darling.
That's an interesting article.
I would like to see the New York times profile
is more like, you know, they're talking about
this guy like he's an entrepreneur.
Like how innovative that he was able to turn
a pardon for war crimes into selling supplements
and the scariest part of it all is that the
right seems to be responding to him positively
as an influencer.
And the only things this guy could influence
people to do in my mind are all bad things
that we don't want anybody doing.
These are people who have had, listen, if
you look at other people who have done horrible
things and have had their careers rehabilitated.
My mind when I was thinking about this yesterday,
particularly because we're talking about Iran
now, my mind went to Oliver North and my mind
went to G Gordon Liddy.
Our younger viewers and listeners may not
know these names all over North, was convicted
in the Iran Contra affair and then he later
ran for office.
His image was totally rehabilitated.
He was in TV on TV all the time.
I actually got an email from someone saying
all the North was on Fox news last night talking
about Iran.
Can you imagine?
Although I didn't see that, if it's not true,
uh, apologies in advance.
G Gordon Liddy was convicted of conspiracy
burglary and illegal wiretapping for his role
in the Watergate scandal.
He later got a radio show, which he may still
have.
I haven't, I'm not really paying too much
in the radio game.
He may still have that.
Um, but really none of this should, should
surprise us at this point because people who
have done really horrible things have had
their careers rehabilitated.
And uh, sometimes we may be okay with it,
sometimes we may not.
But this is a guy who is known only for having
war crimes pardoned by the president of the
United States, and it is immediately becoming
at least somewhat lucrative for him.
We don't really know how much truly sickening
and disgusting.